it's what I want to do is focus on the
real fundamental physical limits of
course getting down to the the
miniaturization and the smallest
possible structures is an important
aspect but there's also a speed aspect
if you even get down to that you get
your density up how fast can you process
the reason I'm quite keen to come back
to computerphile is I spent the first
two years of my physics degree going
shuddered on computer science and
because I'm really quite a per
mathematician to put it mildly but I'm
as a cold or at least back in the dim
distant days of the past I used to be
okay I started with the zx81 got into
assembly language coding did a lot of
from zx80 ones that expect from BBC
micro all that type of stuff used to
love coding my mantra throughout my
undergraduate degree and I was not a
great student was if I can't code this I
don't understand it
so there's a piece of physics
particularly piece of mathematical
physics I'd always think about how do I
call this Fourier transforms convolution
correlation can I reduce this to a piece
of discrete mathematics and therefore
can I actually code it so I've always
loved exploring those links between
programming coding computers information
and physics before we start thinking
about limits we've got to start thinking
about well physically what the computers
do what do they actually do they they
take information in and they do some
computation and they give information
out is that a fair enough description
Sean sounds good yeah so the interesting
thing is just how you define information
and there's a guy called wheeler who was
the PhD supervisor of Feynman what wheel
also had this very famous phrase which
was it from bit so the idea that the
fundamental quantity in the universe is
not energy it's not matter its
information and what does he mean by
that well it's it's it's intriguing
let's play around with these let's say
we've got a system which is entirely
what we'd call reversible right what
does that mean it means that if I drop
that ball let's say you're as you can
see I'm slowing it down but let's
imagine that I was actually just
dropping it out of my hand and it was
coming right back up to the same height
all right that would be what's called an
elastic system there's no energy being
removed this ball is coming right back
up to its same height its end position
is exactly the same as its starting
position it's entirely reversible there
is a link to computing a promise so what
happens if we if we add some if we take
some energy out of this system and
there's this what we call dissipation
this friction does the ball is squishy
so when it hits the floor it's not a
perfectly elastic band it just doesn't
bounce as if it's a rigid object you
know what's gonna happen
it's fairly boring now we've got a
problem because that's our final state
that's a right pot that's a right part
of the system do we have any information
at all about the input from that no not
exactly it's just there you drop it from
this height you drop it from that height
you drop it from that height you've lost
all information about the initial state
however if it's if there's no energy
leaking out of the system then you drop
it from this height if it was a
perfectly elastic system let's do it
like that just to pretend then it comes
back up to the same height this is
already telling us that there are
interesting links between information
and energy now if we look at a standard
to get back into computer files
territory there's a direct relationship
between the reversibility of the system
and the information content of the
output so in the second case when the
balls like that Energy's leaked out the
system isn't reversible and we've we
have no idea what the input was so we've
lost information in that sense has
leaked out into the environment the
fascinating aspect of this is if you
take a NAND gate so what we have now is
a is a logical connection connection and
boolean logic to this physical problem
because let's set this up as a truth
table let's put that as output which is
not how computer scientist might do it
but I'm a physicist so I'll do it this
way so if we go zero zero you all know
how a NAND gate works zero one zero zero
zero one zero one one one
now we've got a problem
because for three of these outputs we've
got exactly the same we've got zero
we've got no connection between this
iPod we've lost information because we
don't know what our inputs were we have
a lack of reversibility and that lack of
reversibility is absolutely key in terms
of the connections between the physical
world and the information world the
computing world and therefore because
we've got a connection from
reversibility and energy therefore we've
got a connection with the physical world
in terms of how we do computation there
are multiple ways of getting to zero is
basically what we've got precisely so if
we've got this we can traverse the
system to know to work out what exactly
are our inputs where there's only okay
forgive me for saying this but is that
not just because we've got two inputs
that only one output through sir thank
you for that exceptionally perceptive
question John so what was and what was
that's exactly the issue so there's a
whole host of gears called fredkin gates
which are developed which have three
inputs and three outputs now we'll go
into them you don't have to forget setup
like this you can have something which
is called a reversible gate and in
principle if you've got that reversible
gate input in place though actually
there's a difference between the physics
and the engineering engineering one of
those gates and actually changing or a
computer architecture to move towards
all type of fredkin gates is going to
take an awful lot of effort and an awful
lot of cost but in principle if we could
do that and if we had a perfect perfect
Fred can get then there would be no
energy cost to computing no energy no no
energy cost because here's the
fascinating thing what costs the energy
is not the computation itself it's a
raising information that and gate there
it's the logic of the of the data but it
doesn't show all the physical
connections does it usually these gates
have multiple things like Earth's and of
course is that right and in fact exactly
they have written in fact how you clear
these in many cases is you ground so if
you've got a 1 which is what is a 1 well
it's a voltage how do you set that to 0
you actually ground it so that's that's
a leaker in that sense you're leaking
out to the environment and that's what
it's a really good way of thinking
because that's exactly what's happening
here this is not this is unravel because
the the information is leaking out to
the environment effectively or in this
case the energy is leaking out to the
environment so you must observe it to
see what happens generally okay so with
it with the sort of threat of going down
the route of an electric engineering
file how does this relate to somebody
who's practicing a modern-day computer
they saw the key thing here is because
it costs a certain amount of energy to
erase data and for any computation in
the way we've set up or to lose data
particularly with these there's an
energy cost to doing this because it's
irreversible that means that that is
setting a fundamental limit in terms of
the the amount of energy that it needs
to power a computer and in turn you know
from both environmental and also
fundamental physics reasons you know we
really need to think carefully about how
we actually beat that limit if we could
beat that limit let's say we do call the
DS fredkin gets what where we really
come up hard against another limit is
something called the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle quantum physics so
don't worry I'm not going to go into a
great deal of detail about the
uncertainty principle apart from to say
this is that too often the uncertainty
principle is seen as you have a system
you make a measurement your influence on
the system is affecting the measurement
and there is affecting the system and
therefore that gives rise to an
uncertainty that's not it at all it's
it's much more fundamental than that
there is in quantum mechanics the
observation effect of the observer
effect that's a whole we could do 15
hours on that and though indeed there
are whole masters courses on that on
that but in terms of the uncertainty
principle actually every time you play a
guitar if you do play a guitar the
uncertainty principle comes it comes
about in a nutshell
the uncertainty principle is is all
about how waves behave and once you down
at the quantum level you've got to think
about particles not just as being
particles as little billiard balls
they've got a way of like characteristic
does that mean they change into waves no
that would be far too straightforward
but it means they've got a way of like
characteristic and therefore the physics
of waves translates all the way there it
must do because we're in viewing matter
with these wave-like characteristics at
the quantum level
so therefore the physics of waves in the
world around us and the mathematical
framework of waves in the world around
us has to move down to that level this
uncertainty principle is just this if I
let that no ring out for a long long
time or indeed if I just whistle maybe a
whistles in pair on for a long time and
I ask you to tell me what the frequency
that whistle is or we look on a signal
analyzer and we look at the spectrum
we'd be able to say as particularly if I
whistle for a very long time that's at
400 Hertz or whatever and some of you
perhaps if you could spectrum analyzer
don't even go back and tell me what
frequency that was that the difficulty
is this what if I do this or what if I
do this how do I describe that what
frequency is a god and the thing is this
wide and time narrow and frequency
narrow in time and in fact if you were
to look at this on a spectrum analyzer
what you'd see is you need a much wider
frequency spectrum to represent that
chunk so when you hear that happening
and lots of metal bands do this what
that is is the uncertainty principle in
action but that's the key thing wide in
time narrow in frequency
narrow in time wide in frequency just
get that again I wish I'd got that idea
in my head as an undergraduate about
three years before I did get it in my
head and then quantum physics would have
been a hell of a lot easier how does
that relate to this well we coming
towards something to do with processing
speed we are indeed that's exactly what
I'm going with this so the question is
to ask yourself let's say with the ideal
technology we had you know everything we
could manufacture down to incredibly
tight limits we could get down to the
single atom limit principle we may even
get below the single-item limit
start controlling nuclei what is the
fundamental physical principle that
really limits us right down at the
lowest possible level we could go to and
what it is is it's the uncertainty
principle
now often it's that the uncertainty
principle is couched in terms of
momentum and position for the physicists
among you there's also a counterpart
which is energy and time at this point
what I'd really like to do is put in a
little aside to all the physicists out
there so if you've got something which
is wide and time it's an hour on
frequency similarly if we try to
constrain it in time the problem is that
we get a much larger range of energy so
if you want to do a computing operation
you've got to think about well the
number of operations you can get by per
second that means if you've got a number
of operations per second that means
you've got a frequency of those
operations also means you've got a time
between those now the uncertainty
principle tells us that we've got a
fundamental limit on how narrow we can
make that time because by narrowing down
that time we broaden out the energy
associated with the atom with the
operation which sets a fundamental limit
because the narrow narrow narrow narrow
we get that the broad on broader and
broader the energy becomes so that's
it's a very fundamental limit when you
work it through and there's this grid
paper ultimate physical limits to
computation which was set alight MIT
back in 2000 this is a freely available
online physics is physics but this
papers 2000 and things have moved on
quite a bit interview 2 but the point
he's making here in fact is he talked
about having the ultimate laptop and in
fact when he means the ultimate laptop
he's not talking about the limit this is
the important thing that's the
engineering limits and then there's the
pure physical limits his ultimate laptop
is a plasma at just a stupidly high
temperature and that's what his ultimate
laptop comes down to and even he talks
about let's reach in terms of the
density of information what happens if
we get to a density of information which
is comparable to the type of effects we
have to consider when we're thinking
about black holes we are not talking
about where the current semiconductor
wherever it seemed gonna be in 20 or 30
years were thinking about where our hard
limits where for an incredibly advanced
civilization where are they gonna stop
and it turns out that if you think about
the uncertainty principle which sets
this this fundamental limit in terms of
the time scale but 10 to the 50 per
second right so this is operations it's
not so much clock speed so it's more
prison to flops what's this day of the
are the moment for flops thank you for
asking me that question cuz I look that
up because being a lowly physicist I
wasn't entirely certain
so the cray are reasonably confident
that by 2020 we'll be at the point where
we have exa flops I believe let me just
check that yeah
one extra flop by 2020 so exaflop so EXA
is 10 to the 18 so 10 to the 18 floating
point logic operations per second there
are some suggestions by 2030 will have
zetas flops so 10 to the 21 operations
per second whereas our ultimate physical
limit in terms of what Lloyd has
suggested 10 to the 50 right so that's
so 50 compared to 21 doesn't seem like a
big number 10 to the 50 compared to 10
to the 21 is a huge huge number in fact
if you work it through so we're about I
don't know let's say we're off order and
meat are shown in terms of height if you
compare us to the diameter of the
observable universe it's 26 orders of
magnitude so 10 to 26 is compared to ten
to the twenty-nine so what were we are
closer to the size of the observable
universe the 92 billion light-years
then-current computing technology is
from the limit yeah from the limit so
we've got a long long way to go
my little question is why have you got
some pink D poppers on the corner so if
you if you start this off and it but
you'd see it disappears energy and it
comes to arrest and what's happening
there was that Energy's leaking out into
the environment